[Music]
hello everyone I'm here with Grandmaster
Nana zagnija Nana had a beautiful game
today congratulations for your win
against the
Grand Master Alexandra Costa new how do
you feel after having had
a rough couple of days but you're back
does it feel good to have won this game
yeah of course at least one game I
managed to win because after
this my game against Conroe game which I
won
um
it was shock to me that after I won this
game after
um three hours I got message from the
chief Arbiter that my result canceled I
know that was a very unfortunate
situation I really don't know what's
what the rule is this and who is writing
such a rules it's really I mean more
sense I think
and yeah it's influenced I think uh the
next question because I I got absolutely
winning position
and I didn't do last two moves with the
bell I are talking right
yeah I got another another shock there
and so after that yeah it was
very difficult to play chess
but yeah it is what it is what can I do
now yeah two more games so
that's unfortunately I'm a tournament
[Music]
it's not what it's have to be
I understand that it was definitely a
tough and a shock for all of us but
of course health comes first and
hopefully fideo will come up with some
better
better rules and
extreme situations so that
players you know I don't know what the
role will be but hopefully they will
come up with something
if you have any ideas feel free to let
them know it shouldn't be like that and
how it's possible you won the game
you earn that point you you work for it
I mean you were preparing some two three
hours before the game you played some
four or five hours game you earn the
point and after some hours they're
telling you that
[Music]
um
you don't have any points
I mean it was totally shocked to me and
I was expecting actually from them too I
mean right to feed and ask something I
don't know because it's such an app sort
I mean I mean yeah there is no doubt I
think about it
so yeah after that uh it was really
difficult for me to contain continue its
same spirits
and uh as the day off had helped you in
any way just kind of yeah yeah actually
maybe but actually after the day of I I
lost again yes I know but
yeah so
I'm looking forward to play to last
around last two rounds okay some good
games and that's it today was was
definitely a good start people have been
asking about to learn more about the
players so I was wondering if you have
any other hobbies that you like to do of
course a chess is your main profession
but what hobbies do you have do you like
reading music yeah reading Walking but
most of the time this I just I spend
with my kids okay yeah
but
um yeah reading Walking and maybe
sometimes Fitness because it's really
when you're a professional just where it
really needs you to be in shape because
um we'll say now I'm I'm playing country
I'm in in a rows third tournament so
without like physical exercise yeah not
to be in a good shape it's impossible so
I tried to do I mean stay in a good
shape do you have something specific
that you like to do swimming swimming
yeah I do some swimming some maybe yoga
a Pilates
some boxing maybe wow okay those are
really nice a lot of chess players now
are doing chess uh and boxing and there
were some um
there was this uh match between
Alexander botes and Dina belenke how are
you not Alexander sorry Andrea botez and
were you watching that did you I have no
idea okay I'll tell you more about it
later
it was it was quite intense so they were
playing chess and and boxing it's it's
getting very intense uh last question
for you can you tell me what is the most
memorable game of yours one that maybe
brought to you uh winning a tournament
or a game that you are very proud of of
yours did you have one yeah exactly
before the pandemic when I won this um
Grand Prix in lausanne in Switzerland
and I read
world champion Jordan
yeah it was a very long game and uh I
did some good night manures I remember
and I won that's very decisive game and
after that I won this tournament because
after that game I was so confident and
uh yeah this game I think I will
remember always okay I will be sure to
check it out thank you so much nana I
wish you good luck in the last two
rounds and uh I'm glad you got your your
focus back together thank you thank you
[Music]
thank you